hello my name is jessica rutkoski and
i'm going to be talking about my
experience adopting a genomic enabled
breeding strategy
although we've made significant progress
in agricultural productivity
there are challenges that still remain
in the state of illinois average net
income per farm in recent years has been
cut in half and at the same time there
are many environmental concerns with our
farming practices for example in the
state of illinois
we're one of the biggest contributors to
nutrient runoff into the gulf of mexico
and so
we have to think of solutions that not
only improve
uh total productivity but they can also
address some of these other challenges
and small grains especially winter wheat
can really help address some of these
challenges because it can provide
some profit stability at the same time
act as a cover crop and help reduce
nutrient runoff
in the state of illinois wheat is
more of a minor crop it
covers about 500 000 acres
most of those acres are in the southern
part of the state
where wheat is grown in a double
cropping system with soybean so the
wheat is planted in the fall harvested
in june july and then the soybean is
planted immediately after that
what's really encouraging is that in
recent years in southern illinois the
profitability of wheat soybean double
cropping has actually been greater than
the profitability of corn soybean or
wheat alone and i believe that if we
focus on improving the profitability of
this system and our region
we can become more prevalent and help us
to diversify agricultural landscape
while also benefiting growers income
improving this profitability of wheat
production support a more diverse
agricultural landscape is actually one
of the major aims of my research as part
of the illinois small grains program
we are actually a combination of two
research labs working on small grains
most of our research is conducted in the
fields and we have one large-scale
field program
we have a very vibrant and high
performing team the pis include me and
dr juan argolize we have graduate
students
research specialists undergraduate
interns a postdoc and the team continues
to grow so if you're interested just
contact me
we all work together and we're all
really passionate about plant breeding
as well as thinking about how to do
things in a different way
now when i got to
university of illinois
right about a year into my time here i
decided that i would take the reading
strategy and really redesign it
starting from a blank sheet of paper and
make it so that it's really optimized to
maximize genetic gain
using all the tools that we have
available especially genomic selection
so how the strategy ended up looking
was
doing rapid generation advancement in
the greenhouse to really get to a fixed
line as soon as possible
genotyping those candidates
doing genomic selection to select
parents and to make advancement
decisions and then in the testing
program
i really redesign it so that
the data and the designs are meant
to help train a prediction model so
instead of having different breeding
stages
separate separately randomized i put all
the material in one sparse fully
randomized testing program to minimize
the amount of compounding
between genetic and non-genetic factors
and that's really because when we're
training genomic selection models we're
putting all the data together we're not
taking separate pieces and
analyzing them separately but we really
want to take everything and put it all
together
to estimate reading values
the other big change that i implemented
was to really well define the breeding
objective and to make it uh very
consistent
and really targeted towards
profitability
to do that i use a profit function to
select lines and crossing parents and i
take the major traits that affect
profitability and just combine them
in such a way that i have an estimate of
the profit potential of every line
the main traits that drive profitability
are the yield early maturity
vomitoxin which is
caused by the bucerium headlight
pathogen and test weight
vomitoxin and test weight affect the
price of the wheat so because if there's
a high vomitoxin or low test weight the
farmer will get discounted when he tries
to sell to the
to the elevator
early maturity is also important because
the earlier that the wheat can be
harvested the sooner soybean can be
planted and the higher soybean yield can
be
obtained i have a profit function that
takes all this and allows me to
uh select kind of an optimal way to
achieve
higher profitability
and it all starts with crossing i use
this net merit function
and
breeding values to actually determine
what crosses to make what are the best
combinations i can predict
the
progeny value of every of each trait for
every possible combination
and then when i go into the greenhouse
i have an algorithm that i
put into a shiny app that will tell me
of the males and females that that are
available that day for crossing what is
the best what are the best crosses that
can be made that day
and
uh so the idea is that every day that i
can make crosses i'm making the best
possible crosses
based on progeny value and net merit
the other big activity is of course
yield evaluation we have currently four
locations
in the state of illinois with 6 000 plus
yield plots
i'm growing this and
through collaborations getting more
locations
and then for out-of-state
locations we have four that are a very
small number of lines for evaluation for
variety release
and as i was mentioning i redesigned the
testing strategy in such a way that it's
completely randomized and i use
partially replicated design so stage one
through four
lines that are in yield trials they're
randomized together and i use partially
replicated design so that only lines at
later stages of testing are being
replicated
that's convenient in two ways one in
later stages of testing we have more
seed so we can actually replicate
and
we also want to get higher quality data
and more information on those material
so that we can make very good variety
release decisions
one important uh
one important feature of this strategy
is that i have one randomization per
field so that the trial effect is the
field effect and there are no additional
non-genetic effects that could be
confounding
here's an example of what that looks
like so there's one field
that i had in urbana this year where i
had a partially replicated design so the
whole field there was just only one
field design and my early stage lines
are here shown in green they were
unreplicated the later stage lines were
replicated these are the ones in white
and
i have blocking to control
the error variants
in addition to just yield of course scab
resistance is a major factor in
profitability because
scab
or fhb causes
vomitoxin to accumulate in the grain
which affects the price that the farmer
will get for the grain at the elevator
for scab resistance screening it's a
really big undertaking we have five
thousand small plots per year it's
inoculated with greenspun inoculated and
misted
and evaluating scale resistance is a
very tedious time consuming
resource intensive task there are
multiple phenotypes
so the disease expresses in different
ways in terms of severity of symptoms
incidents how many spikes are infected
how many kernels are infected how
severely are those kernels infected and
also the vomitoxin or the dawn
as it's otherwise called
this is a quantitative trait there are
many many qtl that have been discovered
they interact with environment and so
this improving this trade is
requires a lot of long-term commitment
and resources
multi-trade genomic selection
is a really good option for
selecting for done resistance to
piecerium especially
for
low dawn or low obama toxin
and how this works is that you have a
training set where you have
information on all the traits so you can
have information on the dawn vomitoxin
uh fusarium damaged kernels incidents on
you know and severity so those are the
spike
um traits the traits that we measure
visually on spikes before harvest and we
have the marker data
and then on our new breeding candidates
we have
all those visual phenotypes again we
have data on these area damaged kernels
but what we don't have on our new
candidates is the information on the
levels of don because don takes a lot of
time to get
the data back we have to send it off to
a lab the lab has to run the analysis
and so typically at the time of
selection we just don't have down data
so what we ultimately
want to do is
use a multi-trade prediction model to
get a good estimate of resistance to don
using all the available information that
we have
we tested this out with a couple of data
sets to
confirm that it's a it's a good strategy
and also to determine
which secondary trades would be most
useful to help predict done
uh here we have uh results from two
different data sets the box plots on the
top of the slide uh correspond to a data
set from the university of illinois then
towards the bottom of the slide there's
results from a data set from purdue you
can see
you see pretty much similar patterns so
the all the way to the left is the
accuracy of prediction using a
univariate model where all we have is
dawn
and then the bars on the right we're
using secondary trait information that
is available on our candidates of
selection as well as in the training set
and what we see actually is that
whenever we have fdk we have a very uh
good
prediction accuracy from
multi-trade genomic selection and if we
uh eliminate fdk from the model then the
accuracy goes down and it's not that
much better than univariate
another interesting observation was that
once we have fdk in the model
using the additional traits incidence
and severity doesn't really improve
accuracy
so this might suggest that we don't
really need to be phenotyping all the
fusarium resistance traits which could
really help reduce the amount of
resources and and time that we spend
with this trade so this is just i think
an example where
in the context of genomic selection
some of our practices and you know even
our phenotyping strategies could
actually be impacted and it could
actually help us
to save resources if we really rethink
and reconsider everything that we're
doing
now given that fdk is such an important
trait and it it really you know shows to
be very helpful in predicting
dawn
we've really focused on how to make that
phenotyping more effective and so one
thing that we're
trying out is doing some
machine learning especially
deep learning
based on images of grain to
to do fdk phenotyping and the ultimate
goal would be to
be able to take a picture of grain
and uh you know with your phone and then
have an app that will actually score fck
right on the spot so that anybody with
very minimal training could very quickly
take ftk data on thousands of green
samples and so that we can get the data
faster be able to spend more time
analyzing it and make better
selection decisions going into the fall
just to summarize we have a vibrant and
innovative small greens breeding and
research program at the university of
illinois we're rethinking every aspect
of the reading strategy in the context
of genomic selection and you know
excellent progress is being made and
we're really building on excellent
work that has been done in the past and
just trying to continually improve the
breeding program process
i just need to acknowledge a lot of
people in the lab uh as well as our
funding sources
and i hope there are time questions
thank you